the Beehive is buzzing Beyonce is
pregnant with twins oh yeah baby that's
right
bee is growing Destiny's children inside
of her belly sending the hive and myself
into a frenzy Twitter says there was
half a million tweets about Beyonce in
the first 45 minutes she shared the
surprise pregnancy news on Instagram
with this floral shot showing off her
groin bump draped with a green veil the
message quote we would like to share our
love and happiness
we have been blessed two times over this
announcement is way more subtle than
when B announced live E would be on the
way at the VMAs in 2011
no word on the gender of the babies but
as you guys all know Beyonce is pretty
private about her family life we all
think n such a beautiful thing you're
gonna have anymore
of course not a mama um I don't know how
many God knows I don't know yet on
Wednesday we got a small peek out what
we didn't even realize with a baby bump
in this promo for her IV park line and
then I let my mind go elsewhere my only
question is what does this pregnancy
mean for the upcoming Grammy Awards and
Coachella either way these two potential
appearances are sure to be a moment but
what
you